when I was in middle school I was in The
Sound of Music yeah and I played we do
fight honor - I'm gonna kill a dude one
of the kids you did yeah I play Kurt the
middle kid I guess yeah so there's a
scene where Fraulein Maria is
introducing you know us to the dude oh
no we're getting introduced to frontline
Maria yeah we're coming down the stairs
and when I'm coming down the stairs we
did like 12 shows hmm every time I would
come downstairs the whole audience would
do a laugh applause break because it was
so funny that I was like the Asian guy
in the middle hmm and every time I go
I'm Kurt I'm 12 whatever the line is
people will go and laugh so I remember
going to the director hey um is there
any way you can change the lines what a
[ __ ] and they're like me yeah no you
have to justify it where each I'm Kurt
I'm adopted just so that you know but
you're making them laugh you're a
comedian you know at the time I didn't
want to be a comedian I was trying to be
a serious actor in this a serious
actress is an Asian and Sound of Music
get your [ __ ] life together directors
fault eh you're a [ __ ] idiot what's
there for even casting me is that what
you're saying or not you're trying to
[ __ ] play a white kid in war-torn
Germany you want them to change the
lines just justify why would there be
out of all these kids yeah the middle
kid is Asian don't you think that's
weird watching a play like that this is
the exist this is the exact it this is
the problem this is California's issue
right now it's like California wants
everybody to [ __ ] and explain like we
need to change the director like look
director we've got a problem like you
know one of the children in one of the
Von Trapps is Asian and they don't feel
really good when they come down the
stairs because people are laughing yeah
because you're a [ __ ] Asian and von
trapp okay okay I get what you're saying
right you can't change the whole [ __ ]
thing it's like black Annie you can't
have a black that is like you can't have
Kathy Griffin play [ __ ] I understand it
but in black Annie but in black Annie
right
she was still black in the show right
she wasn't pretending to be actual white
Annie right me but no I had to be I had
to be white Kurt oh I see that's what
I'm saying right if it was like your on
if it was an all-asian cast and it
wasn't in Germany but it was now in
Singapore right then you wouldn't have
to do it I see we're saying right but
it's like when you're watching white
sound of music and you see one Asian kid
you have to change the lines of it yeah
and good this is Kurt like the dad going
this is Kurt he stands out in the Sun
too long okay just one line right and it
changes the whole and everything that we
can continue the story and it all makes
sense right makes sense I see what
you're saying yeah he likes to run into
walls that's what his face is like a
flat right and they go okay let's move
on
damn dude right he's [ __ ] is a
[ __ ] but dude it is crazy I bet a
lot of people that have deficiencies and
stuff like that what do you mean
immediately think you're their guy you
know like I can see somebody was like a
vitamin deficiency or like severe you
know DNA deficiency or something
immediately being like a chromosome
deficiency being like oh this is our guy
you know this is our mayor you know this
is our Wizard of Oz you know like oh
come on guy guy but I want to say that
you know you know guy can I just say
this guy yeah
it's your tone man is it really yes it
has your tone dude yeah yeah man that's
it my bad
let me say this I remember there was a
time thank you guys for checking out
this clip and if you want to see another
clip and you can look at this clip or
this clip either one of these so did you
pick one or he's still just watching me
do this cuz it's alarming